[Music]
push notifications are a great way to
keep your users engaged and you can send
them directly through your progressive
web app on almost all major browsers now
in today's video you'll learn how to set
up firebase cloud messaging for the web
from scratch and we'll do it in an ionic
floor progressive web app the reason I
chose this topic is because angularfire
2 has now become angularfire and it
lives under the at angular namespace
it's now a stable release with support
for messaging and callable functions
which you'll learn all about in this
video if you're new like and subscribe
and for this video I'm giving away a
one-of-a-kind ionic fire t-shirt all you
have to do is leave a comment below and
I'll pick a random winner by Friday so
today we're talking about web push
notifications which differ from
notifications on native installed apps
like iOS and Android web notifications
work in all major browsers and will feel
just like regular push notifications on
Android devices the big holdout is iOS
Safari so you won't be able to send web
notifications to iPhone users in my
upcoming full course I'll show you how
to set up native iOS notifications for
an installed iPhone app but the lesson
today strictly focuses on web
notifications let's start by taking a
look at what we're building and how it
actually works under the hood the first
thing that happens is the user grants
permission to this app to send
notifications when that happens firebase
will give us a token that we can send
messages to we could use that token to
send a notification to an individual
user or we can subscribe our users to a
specific topic and broadcast
notifications out to everybody at the
same time there are use cases for both
but sending topic-based notifications
tends to be a little more complicated so
that's what I'm going to show you how to
setup today we'll use Kulpa functions so
that we can trigger a cloud function
directly from our front-end by clicking
a button that will subscribe the user to
a topic or unsubscribe them from a topic
and lastly we'll set up a fire store
cloud function that will actually
broadcast out the messages every time a
new document is created in the database
to get started you'll need to have an
existing project and you'll run firebase
and it functions to initialize your
back-end I'm using ionic 4 but you could
write this code in any progressive web
app so I've created a file here called
FCM that's specifically for my messaging
cloud functions and these cloud
functions are some of the
easiest functions that you'll ever write
we are going to use callable functions
which are just like HTTP functions
except that we can pass an information
directly from the firebase SDK so
they're much easier to work with from
your front-end UI as we'll see here when
we get into the front-end code when you
trigger an on call function it gives you
access to a data object which contains
any custom data that you want to pass in
through your front-end so in our case we
want to subscribe the user to a
messaging topic so we'll send this
function the token or the browser that
the users granted permission to and then
also the topic that they want to
subscribe to so we can subscribe a user
to topic based notifications with this
easy one-liner of admin messaging
subscribe to topic with the token and
the topic is arguments then to handle
unsubscribing we can just repeat the
same pattern but instead of calling
messaging subscribe to topic we call
unsubscribe from topic firebase will
keep track of all the tokens subscribe
to a topic and then broadcast out push
notifications to them simultaneously so
it's a really easy way to broadcast out
notifications to millions of devices
simultaneously the last thing we need to
do on the backend is create an event
that will send out a message to the
subscribers to a topic for this demo I'm
pretending that we have a discounts
collection and every time a new discount
document is added it will broadcast a
notification to all the users before
that we can use the firestore document
on create trigger and the first thing
we'll do is set up a variable for the
document data which we'll use to format
the notification content then just to
show you the end of this function the
last thing we'll do is call admin
messaging send with a notification
payload formatting that notification
payload is where you're going to be
doing most of the work as I mentioned
earlier iOS Android and the web all have
different notification api's and the
main thing that they share in common is
the title and body I'm going to create a
notification object that we can share on
all platforms and then I'll customize
things for the web from there and I
highly recommend that you strong type
these because you'll definitely want vs
code intellisense when formatting these
messages at a bare minimum the payload
needs to have the notification content
as well as the topic that you're sending
to and you could actually stop here and
just have a basic notification but we
want to customize things a little bit
more for the web I want my notification
to have a custom icon I want it to
vibrate in a certain way and I want it
to have multiple options with emojis
that the user can click
so we can do this by setting up a web
push object which will have the
parameters that followed the web push
notification API we can pass in an array
of numbers to have the notification
vibrate with a specific pattern we can
pass in a URL for the icon and we can
even pass in an array of actions so the
user can do different things based on a
button that they click specifically on
the notification itself there are even
more options than that but I think
that's good enough for now the next
thing we'll do is deploy our functions
then we'll get into our front-end
angular ionic 4 code so you should have
functions that look like this on the
firebase console and you want to make a
note of the names of the Cobble
functions because we'll need them in the
front-end code web push notifications
are made possible by a serviceworker
that sits in the background of your
progressive web app and listens for
messages to create the worker all you
have to do is go into the source
directory create a file called firebase
messaging - s wjs and then you can copy
and paste this code which is directly
from the firebase Doc's the only thing
you're required to change is the sender
ID for your specific firebase project
then with an ionic angular project
you'll need to go into the angular JSON
file and you'll need to add the path to
this file to the assets array this tells
angular to include this file in your
production build the next thing we want
to do is make sure that we have
angularfire installed in our project you
can follow the official install
instructions in the main repo then the
next thing I'm doing is generating a
service in my app called FCM this will
handle pretty much all of our front-end
code including getting permission from
the user showing the notification while
the app is active and subscribing to
specific topics I'm working from an
existing app with additional services
but you don't have to worry about those
in the service will be using angular
fire messaging angular fire functions
and ionics toast controller now
currently there's a bug with angular
fire messaging which might already be
fixed by the time you're watching it but
if not this is some code you can use to
fix it I'll add a link to the github
issue in the description the first thing
we'll do is set up a token as a property
on the service then we can inject our
dependencies in the constructor when a
message is sent with the app running in
the foreground we're not going to send
the notification to the device but we'll
just handle it directly in the app we
can do that really easily out of the box
with ionics toast controller so I'll
create an async function here called
make
host then we just called the toast
controller create and add whatever
parameters we want on that toast message
this will give us a toast message at the
top of the screen that fades out after
five seconds and has the option to
dismiss the next thing we need to do is
get permission from the user you can run
this method when your app is first
initialized or you can run it on a
button click but basically it's just
going to bring up this pop-up window
asking the user to grant permission to
your app to send notifications
angularfire messaging has a method
called request token that returns an
observable and when we subscribe to it
I'm going to set the token as a property
on this service so we can use it later
with our callable functions the other
thing we want to do is listen to the
stream of incoming messages and then
handle them accordingly in our front-end
we've already set up a method to show a
toast message so we'll go ahead and make
use of that we'll pipe in the tap
operator then take the notification body
and use that as the content for the
toast message so every time firebase
broadcasts out a new message it was
handled by ionics toast controller in
the UI then the last piece of the puzzle
is to create a couple of methods to call
our callable functions and this is
actually almost as easy as writing the
function itself we can say angular fire
functions HTTP callable and in the
function name if you remember subscribe
to topic is the function name that we've
already deployed to our back-end and
then we can pass in the topic and also
the token that we have set up for this
device this also returns an observable
so I'm going to again make use of our
make toast method to show a toast
message once this request has completed
then we'll do the exact same thing to
unsubscribe from a topic but just
calling a different function so that
handles all the complicated stuff now we
just need to go into a page inject our
service and put it to use for this demo
which is part of my ionic full course we
have an FCM page then I also have a
database service which will create a
document and fire store in the discounts
collection triggering a message to be
sent to all subscribers to that topic
but that codes not very important it's
just a simple fire store document right
and the way I have it set up for this
demo is that it will create a random
discount percentage then if you remember
from our function it's looking for a
headline property on the document to
I'm at the content for the push
notification so this way we'll get a
different random number for every
notification so we can verify that
everything is working as intended now we
can just call our FCM methods directly
on ionic buttons so we have three
different buttons set up in here one to
request permission one to subscribe to a
topic and then one to broadcast the
message when we open the app and click
the grant permission button it will have
to pop up giving us the option to allow
or block notifications then I'm
displaying the token in the UI which is
just a big long string then I'll click
subscribe to topic to call our callable
function and that will bring up a toast
letting us know that we're now subscribe
to the discounts topic and lastly I will
send the notification by creating a
document in a fire store which then
triggers the cloud function to send the
message when the app is in the
foreground like it is now it will just
show the ionic toast message but when it
happens with the app in the background
it will trigger the notification on the
browser itself or on your phone if
you're running Android I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to learn how
to set up notifications on iOS and
Android
I'd recommend upgrading to a pro
membership to get access to my fully on
a course which covers native features in
a little more detail thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you soon
[Music]
you